now that we've covered querying with our
content provider it's time to start
inserting data let's take a look at the
incomplete content provider insert
function we provided in the source code
as you can see this function takes
advantage of the URI mattre code but it
only requires the base URIs that's
because inserts are fundamentally
simpler we simply want to make sure that
the right record ends up in the right
table the data that is contained in the
other you are eyes such as location and
date will actually be in the content
values used in the insert note that if
we wanted to we could support all of the
you our eyes here but it makes the
implementation of the insert function
far more complicated when we insert into
the database we wanted to notify every
contents Observer that might have data
modified by our insert it turns out that
cursors register themselves as notify
for descendants which means that
notifying the root you are I will also
notify all descendants of the URI ones
that contain additional path information
just like with calling our content
providers we can use a content resolver
to notify our content observer as you
can see the route URI for each table in
sunshine just contains the content scope
the authority and the table name in the
case presented the content URI that
contains a date is a descendant of the
plane weather content URI if we notify
based on anything other than the route
URI then a cursor listening on the route
you are I will not get notified of a
change that would certainly impact it so
we have to be very careful when doing
that let's go back to the source code
for whether we just pass the parameters
that came into the content provider into
the database insert call we should throw
an exception if the insert fails the
only trick here is to make sure we
return the correct value which is a URI
fortunately we made a function to build
these URIs which contain the weather
path followed by an ID if we were being
complete in our content provider
implementation we should also implement
these URI types in the contract you are
I'm a chore in query function but the
beautiful thing about implementing a
content provider especially if it's only
being used by your application
is that you only need to implement the
features you use so we just set the
return URI by using the build whether
you are I function